- [Voiceover] We're told,
suppose a+b=2a.
Which of these expressions equals b-a?
Alright, I encourage
you to pause the video
and see if you can figure that out.
Which of these expressions
would be equal to b-a
and it's going to just involve
some algebraic manipulation.
Alright, let's work through this together.
So we are told,
we are told that a+b=2a
so the first thing I would want to do is
get all my a's in one place
and one way I could do that is
I could subract a from both sides.
So if I subtract a from both sides
I'm going to be left with
just a b on the left-hand side
and on the right-hand side
I'm going to be left with
2a-a, well that's just going to be a.
If I have two of something
and I subtract one of them,
take away one of them I'm going to have
just one of those somethings equal to 1a.
So we want to figure out what b-a is.
Well luckily I can figure that out
if I subtract a from both sides.
So if I subtract a from both sides
well then I'm going to
get on the left-hand side
b-a, which is what we want to figure out,
is equal to a-a=0.
So b-a=0 which is not one of the choices.
Alright, so let's see if we can figure out
some other things over here.
So b-a=0 but that is
not one of the choices.
Alright, so let's see is there
any other way to manipulate this?
No, b minu- I could just go straight ahead
and subtract 2a from both sides
and I would get b-a=0.
Oh, this is interesting,
this is a tricky one.
So b-a=0.
Well, if b-a=0 then if we take
the negative of both sides of this,
if we take the negative of both sides,
if we multiply both sides by -1.
So x, I should write the times,
I should write like this,
alright, because we don't want to
confuse it with the variable x,
so if we multiply both sides by -1
what do we get?
Well on the left-hand side we get a-b
and on the right-hand side we still get 0.
If b-a=0 then the negative of it,
which is a-b is also
going to be equal to 0.
And that's this choice.
That is, let me do that
in a little darker color,
that is this choice right over there.
That was a good one.